[Music]
jessica is with us in Seattle hi Jessica
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Heidi
nice to talk to you you too we took your
thank you we took your Financial Peace
University class and we completed it and
are now debt-free including our mortgage
so we are thinking about upgrading our
home and buying a new house which would
require us to get another mortgage we
would probably own about us be able to
pay it off in seven to ten years so
early but I just wanted your input on
that because you know our goal is to not
be in debt but in order to upgrade our
house you're gonna have to do that
so what's your current home worth it's
worth about six hundred and fifty
thousand mm-hmm and the show your
upgrade would be to what how much 950
and what's your household income about a
hundred and eighty thousand a year
mm-hmm okay and so you need three
hundred thousand bucks making one
hundred and eighty you can't do that in
three years by saving a hundred thousand
dollars a year for three years making
one hundred and eighty to pay down the
mortgage no to save up and buy a house
oh I don't know I guess that would be I
guess we could do that it would be tough
why would it be tough you don't have any
payments you live in a $650,000 house
when does tough start in this
conversation right I guess what I'm
worried about is real-estate prices
going up there is crazy
you
looked at a house you got house fever
that's what happened you got a house
fever bad was it the kitchen or the
outdoor grilling area that got you what
got you it's a new house on a lake oh
it's on the lake
there's the lure hanging out of the lip
I know you've been hooked the Bible says
out of the abundance of the heart the
mouth speaks and you've been speaking
hooked for the last few minutes while I
was talking to you you were you were in
deep I could tell oh stop that stop
you're rich okay you can do whatever you
want to do nothing in this discussion
falls under the crazy your stupid column
if you guys want to go take out a
mortgage and pay it off it shouldn't
take you seven years though that's kind
of ridiculous let's at least pay it off
in three or four or five but if you go
do that nobody's gonna call you crazy
you did call Dave Ramsey and ask him to
go back in debt after you finally got
everything paid off you know you just
did that right thing where you stick
your head in the mouth of the lion you
remember that I'll think anyway so what
what I do
I don't borrow money and I can't
conceive of ever going back into debt
once I finally got out okay I can't I
can't get my head around that
and you know that you and yeah you went
to my class you went to my class and you
know what I'm gonna say but I'm not I'm
just I'm just messing around with you to
make you think okay so again I'm not
going we're gonna be friends and I'm not
going to shame you for doing whatever
you do in this conversation because even
what you presented to me is not crazy
it's really ultra conservative by
cultural standards and you're gonna be
fine you're not gonna go bankrupt
you're not like somebody's got a $50,000
car note and makes 40 thousand a year
you're not that person okay
you just got lake house fever and I
don't blame you I got a house on the
lake - oh really
so I want you to get one if I were in
your shoes I don't borrow money so I'd
have to save for three years in pay cash
regardless or real estate prices did
might be four years the real estate
prices might go up faster than I can
save I don't know it's possible but but
if you get this mortgage let's have the
idea that we don't want a mortgage which
is competing with your lake house idea
so how do we cause that to reconcile we
either save up and pay cash for the move
up and then make the move or we take a
mortgage with the idea we're going to
pay it off three four five years max
this is the Dave Ramsey show